good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Tuesday hope
everyone's having a great day so far hey
Jax how are you doing darn good gearing
up for Thanksgiving were two sleeps from
Thanksgiving you guys I hope everyone is
making space in their bellies so that
their bellies can be full and their
smiles can be wide I also hope everyone
is really acknowledging the space that
they're in I feel like so many times
throughout the year I'm like oh I wish
it was the holiday season I wish there
was Christmas music and Christmas trees
and you know holiday cheer and it's
actually here and it goes by so fast so
like next thing you know it's going to
be February there's going to be no you
know federal holidays coming up at least
give me a dark time at least February
gives us Valentine's Day which is
spirited and President's Day and March
is the bitter month and Harry's birthday
How Could You Forget and my anniversary
right oh speaking of
Groundhogs Day
will the groundhog see his shadow
spoiler alert I don't know but I know
that it will mean a Long Winter or will
our new mayor follow in the footsteps of
our first mayor and accidentally kill
Punxsutawney Phil
I don't know if he killed him he dropped
him he altered his life forever and so
are they all called Punxsutawney Phil I
think they are it's like a generational
thing it's like you get the name when
you're it's like Royal
Royal you got thank you for bringing
that up I got my gift box yesterday from
Buckingham Palace and you guys if you
are a royal girly like me you have to
treat yourself to its gifts
speaking of Harry's birthday Jackie
asked me how I'm done how are you doing
you know I'm done better because I told
you this last night and when I woke up
it was you know still very much going on
we are in the process of going viral on
Tick Tock but not in the way that we had
hoped we're getting some backlash you
said we're getting some backlash on what
I thought was such a funny clip
um about Miss rage Miss Rachel as for
those who don't know is you know the
YouTuber changing lives she's changed
the lives of members of our own family
that's how we know Michaela loves Miss
rage she learned so many new words from
Miss rage new songs
um so we were talking about her
yesterday on the on the toast about how
you know Miss Rach has going through
like a little bit of a scandal kind of
kind of because she told her audience
that she received like a very upsetting
email and that people you know are so
hurtful and it was just a reminder to be
kind and what we said and which is what
we clipped on um on our Instagram and
our Tick Tock was that you know it's
unacceptable for Miss Rach to be getting
hate you know if Miss Rach is getting
hate what has the world come to we must
protect Miss Rach and then we were
joking around about how much Ray check
needs to get a thicker skin because like
it's one email girly like
you know get over it
um I thought it was funny like we were
obviously joking we obviously respect
Miss Rach that's why we like know who
she is I don't even have kids like we
respect but the mamas just have
descended would you like for me to read
some of the comments to you please you
shared some last night I didn't agree
with the take
but Everyone's entitled to their opinion
and then also the other half of what we
said was like that makes us feel a
little better like if Miss Rach gets
hate then like you could really be
perfect and you'll still get hate so
here's the top comment okay but the
difference here is Miss Rach is actually
a precious angel
oh that one that bites yeah meaning that
would not we deserve hate that one has
teeth yeah this and this is pretty much
what everyone was saying like this is
giving passive aggressive mean girl
vibes okay
okay
sure
here's the thing sure sure like not
everyone is gonna be nice all the time
and we're just gonna be honest and
that's how it made us feel if that's
called mean girl Vibes then sure and
also mgv here here's the thing I'm
totally okay with like people not
agreeing with things we say on the
podcast because you know we live in a
free country and thankfully that's a
privilege that we have
um but what I get annoyed at is when
people get mad at us for things we
didn't say we didn't say we want Miss
Rach to get hate and everyone's like not
you encouraging hate to we never said
that we actually no literally not us
encouraged not us no people are like um
like not you guys like being happy that
Miss Rachel is getting hate like you're
I literally am not happy
did I say that
so if you're gonna be mad be mad at the
things that I said but like just because
you're negative and toxic and like you
are inferring things from this like
that's on you my friend that's on you
yes now I need to call us out because oh
we just like Miss Ranch got one email
and she made a whole thing about it like
we got one Tick Tock real comments
section that didn't go our way it wasn't
one comment there's like there's like
400 comment section but we've hosted a
million tick tocks of and people love it
they lap it up yeah and I talk about it
all the time all this rage and then we
got one comment section that didn't go
our way and we're talking about it just
like Missouri well here's the thing
about complaining I just thought like
you should know I thought like the toast
Universe should know like we are getting
dragged we're getting dragged I am
totally cool with that I think you know
controversy raises All Ships
controversial Tides raise All Ships and
so that's really what they're saying
like if that's the controversy like cool
oh and it was people who have like never
you know heard of our podcast because
it's just like not for them and we're
reaching new audiences no brunette girl
needs to stop talking over redhead girl
brunette girl does need to stop talking
over my head girl brunette girl does
it's so it's so funny last yesterday I
put together the
audio in the video for the show because
you were freezing at the studio and it's
like I don't know when you're supposed
to be speaking at me because you're
speaking over I have to that's why
instances where you're done speaking and
I come in that's why it's so important
that I edit the video and audio every
day because I know like when my annoying
ass chimes in and I know until time it
up right you know got it
um so that's just like a little digital
news about us you know extra extra real
about it I did want to ask because you
know the people who have descended Upon
Our comment section it's the mama
community and for me like of course
they're gonna hate me
um but like you are a part of that
Community do you feel like in a way
you're letting down your community no I
feel like they let me down like
mamas like chill out
but I don't feel like that's not the I
mean you read the commenting you just
read them to me I wasn't getting the
vibe that they were from Mama's I was
getting the vibe that they were from
like zillennials who were just like you
can't like anything about hatred that
she's getting no it was the Mama's
Community because they're all like
commenting at each other like yeah like
Mama's coming together
no I don't like that it was the Mama's
community so um I respect the Mama's
community so
I but you know what I feel like this is
a good lesson like not all Mamas are the
same and that's like you shouldn't
expect that they're going to be and that
they're all going to like the same
things like we're all still different we
were different before yes we have this
mama ing trait in common but right it's
not to be expected that like all Mamas
are gonna be toasters or or this or that
if only we'd be raising a generation of
queens and kings
exactly
so we actually have a fabulous show
because yesterday there was like some
crazy news that came out we've got the
Chrisley sentencing which I have so many
thoughts on
um and just lots of good stories so is
there anything else you want to catch up
on I didn't really do much yesterday
besides freeze my nipples off and you
and I actually recorded a really fun
interview for a panel coming up with
Taylor strecker that we'll share I think
it's coming out in a few weeks so that
was fun just talking about like business
things business things it was nice like
State of the Union to like reflect on
our business you know the decisions that
we've made consciously the things that
have happened sort of by a happy
accident it was fun it was really nice
and just getting to spend more time with
you is a dream
chat and I feel like I got a lot I feel
like I spoke a lot which was new for me
you know oh my God you're such a victim
sometimes like you're fine you know what
I'm doing tonight no like
what are you doing
remember I told you about that show I
wanted to see that was like uh Titanic
retelling using all Celine Dion music
but like the time I was supposed to go
like one person in the theater got
covered and they shut down the whole
thing I'm finally going again tonight
That's so exciting everyone keeps
tagging me in this Titanic Museum that
has popped up in the city and it's like
a recreation of the Titanic like the
rooms the everything uh I want to try
and go would you be interested in going
to make you happy yeah well I don't need
to like trust me on the list of things
I'm not desperate to do dragging you to
a museum that you're not interested in
is probably number one
would it be the week that you're here in
December it would be the week that I'm
there yeah that week doesn't work for me
I'm filming my comedy special the week
is booking up photo shoots we have video
shoots it's the tpg awards we're doing a
spritz party like I honestly what party
December 9th are you still here yeah
okay you're gonna have to come and
you're gonna like it you'll eat it I'll
tell you all about it you'll eat it and
you'll like it you'll like it yeah
I got these chocolates from Buckingham
Palace
no I only had one it was so delicious I
felt like Miss trunchable because for
the biscuits I didn't have a biscuit yet
because I wasn't having a tea and I I
already tried a chocolate so I didn't
want to go through all my sweet treats
but I felt like Miss trunchbully much
too good for children and I like to do
good for children they come in like
those little things
um where each chocolate has a little
paper around it you know like a oh
that's so mistructure it was so
mistrenchable and I'm like giving them
to some people not to other people
sensing someone's in your home
you know yes
um also speaking of movie quotes
yesterday I did find the person in our
comment section who was the first to
comment where this quote was from that's
the way you should feel your whole life
um it was Paper Towns Cara delevingne's
famous line I never even saw the movie
she just said it in the trailer and I
thought it was like such a weird thing
to say
um
we should go watch the trailer and like
see if it's as crazy no because we have
like we've larped it that's the way you
should feel your whole life like that's
definitely not how she said it but I
venmoed the toaster she sent me the
money back and I sent it back again
[ __ ] keep it she finally kept it and
then she we were like commenting to each
other like on the venmo um
like transaction
yeah and she wrote the funniest movie
reference but I can't remember it hold
on
how do I find it
pen was the worst platform
we were like commenting back another
towards wanting each other like
where is it check your email
do you get an email
no she was being so funny and she quoted
like such a niche movie reference that
was like something we would do in our
family mm-hmm
how the [ __ ] do I find it like
all right whatever
I found it
two comments
what is it oh she said okay I'll keep it
begrudgingly but I'll leave you with
another Niche reference
frittata
oh that's good so good right now if you
know what that's from leave it in the
comments of this YouTube video double or
nothing 20 bucks to the this is like a
dangerous precedent descent 20 bucks to
the person who knows what frittata is
from first person to comment it and
leave your venmo username to twenty
dollars to you where should they be the
first person to comment it I think on
YouTube
on YouTube but what about podcast
listeners who podcast goes up first and
they comment on our Instagram well
that's what they get for not supporting
our YouTube dreams would you rather them
watch on YouTube or listen as a podcast
and help us climb the charts it's the
same to me yeah so why can't they
comment on the Instagram
because like
then it's just like so many platforms
you don't know who actually okay so it's
a YouTube team it's a YouTube game okay
and maybe we'll hit 200 000 subscribers
while we do it yeah for sure
so we've got a great show I'm ready to
dive in Jax if you are I am do you
notice I'm wearing your necklace today
no I didn't come closer
stunning
I wore it the day after my birthday but
that was the day that my camera had an
astigmatism so I feel like people didn't
really get to see it I'm Gonna Come a
Little Closer because it's like
it's truly stolen it's so beautiful
little necklace ASMR
oh okay
these microphones don't pick up ASMR I
feel like they got mine
I feel like they got it too
okay now without further Ado the stripes
Brethren don't come to work anymore
because they don't support working women
here are the fast side stories that you
need to know
Deb
today's episode is brought to you by
Skylight frame a photo frame that you
can update instantly by email or from
anywhere it is an effortless way uh to
stay in touch with the ones that you
love especially those that might not be
like the most tech savvy Skylight frame
is a digital frame that really is so
easy like your grandma could do it
anyone can do it and you can do it for
your grandma so it's great I feel close
it's a great way to feel close to those
you love even when you're separated and
it takes under 60 seconds to set up plug
it in touch the screen connect your
Wi-Fi network and enjoy sending photos
to the frame is super easy too everyone
in the family can use their app or just
email them to the Skylight frame and
it'll pop up in seconds multiple people
can send photos to the frame so it's a
great way to keep large networks of
friends and families in touch it has a
black and white mat so it looks like a
real photo frame that adds a beautiful
touch to your home Timeless
um
their touchscreen display is super
vibrant it lets you swipe through photos
you could tap to Heart it to let the
person who sent the photo know that you
love it they have two sizes either the
original 10 inch or the new 15 inch
frame they have 100 satisfaction
guaranteed so if you don't love your
Skylight they'll offer you a full refund
um this is the perfect gift for the
holidays so if you haven't gotten
someone
um a gift yet Skylight frames is
everything of the sort and we can get
you 15 off your purchase of the Skylight
frame when you go to skylightframe.com
and enter code toast that's right to get
15 off your frame of your purchase of a
skylight frame go to skylightframe.com
code toast that is
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com promo code
toast I was just at um a friend's house
who had gotten them a skylight frame for
their wedding for and it was like really
at the center of their home it was such
like a nice way of displaying it it
really is such a nice gift and again
Skylight frames Skylight frame.com promo
code toast will get you 15 off today's
episode is also brought to you by seed
turns out everything you think you know
about probiotics may be wrong like those
probiotic tortilla chips sounded way too
good to be true and the good news is
that seeds ds01 daily symbiotic is the
real deal because not all probiotics are
created equal so the C ds01 daily
symbiotic is a broad spectrum
plant-based Prebiotic and a 24-strain
probiotic formulated for Digestive gut
immune and additional systemic benefits
its capsule and capsule protects against
stomach acid digestion enzymes and bile
salts for viability through digestion so
what does that mean the live probiotics
will actually make it to the end of the
small intestine for delivery into your
colon if you've taken a probiotic form
you didn't feel a difference it's likely
because the good bacteria wasn't
surviving in your GI tract well seed is
designed differently and that's why it
works it supports benefits in and Beyond
the gut so their ds01 will support ease
of bloating Health irregularity ease of
evacuation which means you're going to
be making nice big soft duties but it'll
also help your gut barrier your skin
Health your heart health and your
micronutrient synthesis so if you want
to start a new healthy habit do it today
with Sid visit seed.com toast use the
code toast to resume redeem 20 off your
first month of seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic it's seed.com toast
s-e-d.com slash toast and use code toast
for 20 off your first month
thank you mclart for the big talk for
those tips on how to make a big soft
Duty
the thing is you know when you open up
different podcasts in your app like you
know from certain podcasts you're going
to get news certain podcasts you're
getting at history you know when you
open up the toast like at least once a
day I will tell you something about how
to make your life better when it comes
to your duties to make a BSD
Squatty Potty
seed
seed
okay our first story some legal reality
TV news Todd and Julie Chrisley are
sentenced in bank fraud and tax evasion
case Todd Chrisley received 12 years in
prison in 16 months probation while wife
Julie Chrisley received seven years in
prison plus 16 months probation
according to Insider and Fox 5 Atlanta
prior to the sentencing Todd and Julie
asked for leniency in a statement Todd
said his wife who is the caregiver for
their son Grayson who's 16 and their
granddaughter Chloe who's 10 he said his
wife should not be punished to the same
extent Julie was emotional as she
described a conversation with Chloe who
is the daughter of their estranged son
Kyle the Chrisley's former accountant
Peter Tarantino was also sentenced to 36
months in prison on Monday Tarantino was
set to report to prison on May 1st after
under undergoing hip surgery the couple
sentencing had been delayed from October
26 to yesterday after their lawyer
claimed to witness lied on the state and
prior to the sentencing Federal
prosecutors requested the judge sentence
Todd to between 17 and 22 years and
Julie to 10 and 13. so the sentences
were actually a little lower than
recommended they are also asking that
the pair forfeit nearly 20 million
dollars according to court documents
obtained by Wagga
I mean this is so crazy of course like I
can't even talk about this without
thinking about what this means for Jen
Shaw even though she's being tried in
New York and they were tried in Georgia
but it's clear that like you know
Financial crimes from like people of a
certain celebrity like are not taken
lightly because this is still even
though it's less than the recommended
sentence it's a really like it's a harsh
sentence for like a non-violent crime
yes also gen shot defrauded people the
Crystal East afforded the government
they also defrauded Banks so like yes
what they did which was so crazy is
obviously like the usual mail fraud tax
evasion but they also were like creating
false documents to give to banks in
order to procure loans being like we
make this amount of money so we you can
give us five million dollars in loans
yeah
collateral right they would take that
loan you don't have to pay taxes on a
loan and they would just live off of
that loan so I don't know like what the
[ __ ] they thought they were doing but
like it's illegal in their consequences
but like I just wasn't expecting that
yeah that's a big Whopper of a sentence
I don't think any celebrity case should
be tried any differently than so lay
person case whether it's harsher or more
lenient I think right they do often like
make examples out of yeah celebrities I
don't know that that needs to happen
either I don't know that that's what
happened here because it's they got less
than what the prosecutors were
recommending which is typically what
happens I think but I feel like there
are people who like rape and don't even
get that many years am I wrong
that's a good point like it's it's a
terrible crime don't get me wrong like
you should not steal it's you know shout
not steal right but when you compare it
to the sentences of like people who like
actually commit violent crimes like
armed robbery I feel like I never even
like I'm always surprised when I hear
that's what like a life sentence is
technically 25 years right yeah so how
is tax evasion everything 11.
that's a really interesting point yeah
and I'm not saying like there shouldn't
be consequences for your actions like
they they definitely knew what they were
doing was totally legal and then to go
on TV is a level of stupid I just cannot
relate to and I'll never understand why
people do that well what do you think
came first do you think they were on TV
and they needed to keep up this
lifestyle or they were being fraudulent
way before they were on TV and I'm sure
it's in the documents I mean they were
living like even uh like a more fancy
lifestyle before they were on TV because
when we season one they were in this big
old house and they had a million cars
and then as the seasons progressed like
they moved into a smaller house it's
almost like they downsized a little bit
but also their kids grew up could have
been like a smaller house that was like
nicer and more updated and in a better
part of town Swanky right
it's just I mean do not [ __ ] with the
federal government in Georgia like this
is I was just I was really shocked by
the length yeah especially because like
my bar thus far for things like this is
Teresa and Joe and Teresa having to go
for like what was it like two years a
year a year and a half and then Joe
having to go for three plus the
detention center for um ice like that's
my bar and that was so crazy to me yeah
also like the situation is a good um
Mike The Situation is a yes
so when you compare to that yes this
this uh sentence does seem outsized
especially when you also compare it to
the violent crimes violent crimes so I
mean like
it's a kind of sad no I mean but like
they did that [ __ ] but like it is like
someone's parents like go to jail for so
long like
you think about like Savannah's what
like 21 in the next 10 11 years like
she'll have kids like it like it is sad
when you think about it from that
perspective and it does seem like a
harsh sentence but like don't break the
law you know yeah
mm-hmm
no now I'm like
it's like I pay my taxes at the end of
the year I'm like checking double
dotting my eyes crossing my T's I'm like
one of my biggest fears is like
accidentally tax evading yes but I feel
like there are people who accidentally
tax evade where it could either happen
accidentally where like it's a
you know I'll pay it away you know like
situation sort of thing and like the
sentence was smaller for that like I
think that what they were doing was so
intentional then also the lying to the
banks like it's not something that that
could ever happen by accidentally go out
of your way yeah I mean I actually wrote
about this in my book how like when I
first started making money on the
internet
um I guess in 2017 I underreported my
taxes my income I wasn't entirely sure
how much money I made and I didn't have
like a proper like team in place
um and then like years later because the
IRS is like so backdated I got like a
crazy letter that scared the [ __ ] I
thought I was going to jail like I was
so scared for like you underreported and
it took us two years to figure it out to
you it was two years of penalties
and I was like so happy to not be going
to jail I paid the whole thing and fall
I'm like yes sir it's right here thank
you so much have a great day yeah
influencers doing their taxes isn't it
really subject because I feel like
there'll be a documentary well not even
I mean maybe there are people who are
trying to get away with funny business
but if you're an influencer and like
you're doing like freelance work for
different brands and you have a lot of
different like streams of income like
even if it's like
not even streams just like places that
pay you it's really hard to organize
your stuff for taxes so you really have
to be on top of it so if any of you are
influencers in any way shape or form
Aspire bigger sponsors like big or small
make sure that you have your tax
situation figured out because it can
really get away from you right like the
second you start making money like
invest in a good accountant or like a
business manager it's worth your it's
worth every penny yeah
an accountant should do it right up you
send them all your 1099s and everything
yeah and and they'll help you sort it
out so that's our tip of the day for all
the aspiring influencers or just
aspiring small business owners business
owners you want to start any side hustle
like get your paperwork together first
because it's a lot it's it'll be a
bigger headache down the road if you
just like push it off yes but like a
small business owner has like the one
business income and it's a little more
clear-cut on how to do your streamlined
yeah when you are I guess any sort of
contractor
who has a lot of different uh people
paying you definitely keep your antennas
up no like this let this also be a
cautionary tale to anyone who gets like
caught up in like you know Fame and
money like it's not worth it no it's not
on top for three years and then you
spend 11 in jail none of it matters none
of it nothing matters because at the end
of the day you're alone with yourself in
your jail cell right so would you rather
be in a jail cell or in a house that was
like smaller than the one that you had
dreamed of right right and maybe for
some people like that's the the peak is
worth the pit yes it's a risk they're
willing to take right yeah not me can't
really like one of my biggest fears I
know probably my biggest fear period is
going to jail
you're not cut out
oh no
I don't know but
I don't know I would definitely start
like a musical theater you would like I
think you can also get a lot of time to
read
I get but I can't have a Kindle right I
have to go paper you have to go paper
but I think they have a library so yeah
but they don't have like no you wouldn't
be able to read Coho all day long but
you don't have to Branch out to other
genres yeah I also would like probably
start working out because there's
literally nothing else you'd get like
shredded
well it depends what kind of prison I'm
going to like the one Teresa went to
like was very much like it was still
prison but it was like a retreat like
you had like an hour of Internet time
working out so yeah but like I'm talking
about like the prisons like from from
like the movies
um
like lawlessness recklessness like
there's no Shawshank Redemption right or
that episode of SVU that literally
scarred me when I was a kid when Mariska
Hargitay went undercover with iced tea
and iced tea was getting a flu shot so
he was waiting in line and not able to
help Marishka when the guard they were
investigating for sexual assault
assaulted Marishka
that episode changed like literally
changed the DNA like of who I am
yeah
is that one of my like stories
yeah it's not not one of them add it to
the list
you know what where's my
it is totally like one of those stories
let's see what what's going on with
Claudia's list and see if anything needs
any updating yeah well I definitely
think we can add the Mariska Hargitay
episode Claudia's repeated stories okay
so Dennis's funeral
Dennis's funeral Keenan's Uber drivers
yes
starex armed hike I'll never stop
talking about it Law and Order jail
episode flu shot
iced tea Marishka
great
um and you wanna know your regrets or no
I could tell you them uh not getting in
the cop car yep
I have five others
five so many regrets
the Yeezus jacket
oh that's a major regret not going to
the life of Pablo concert oh you know
what I could take that one off now yeah
yeah [ __ ] Andre all the trouble he's
gotten me into like but first the
Confederate flag then uh Red Taylor
Swift concert huge
starting the TMT Facebook group
huge
and not having Taylor struck her at your
wedding
huge
yeah that's beautiful okay don't you
like that I have this list going on I
love because you're like you know my
memory is not what it used to be I'm
responsible for your memory you are
literally like the Secretary of my
memories of your brain you're like
filing all like you're in charge of the
filing cabinets you know what I'm doing
um out running your memory feels like
I'll run in the Wind
can't get where I'm going if I can't
leave where you've been
stunning thank you are you ready for our
next story
am I ready for our next story that's
such a good question
I am great because Dancing with the
Stars season 31 wow that's a lot of the
damn Seasons it is has ended and our
winner has been crowned spoiler alert
the winner is
Charlie demilio now let me tell you how
genuinely shocked I am that the
classically trained dancer with hundreds
of millions of followers and a reality
show on the same platform as Dancing
with the Stars the fact that she won is
so crazy to me I mean what a what a you
know it's a trial it's an upset yeah
it's I'm shocked it well it's really
beautiful because I feel like it shows
anyone that anyone can do anything if if
you are no matter how little experience
you have no anyone can do anything if
you are the exact right person for the
role in every way shape and form what
confuses me about Dancing with the Stars
because I definitely feel like it's not
really 100 based on the votes
um is like by this logic wouldn't JoJo
see I have one
so Jojo siwa I mean you know her on Tick
Tock where she is extremely popular
popular
um but to me she doesn't have the same
popularity as Charlie demilio and agreed
I haven't seen JoJo siwa dance like to
me JoJo siwa doesn't dance she just like
jumps no she's like she's like a very
she was very good too okay but Charlie
demilio I was watching one of her final
dances and I was reminded of how on the
demilio show like she has a ballet
studio in her house and she's like
training as a dancer it's so now watch
like realizing this I'm like I should
have put money on who was gonna when
Dancing with the Stars because it's so
[ __ ] obvious not only is she just as
good a dancer as the pros really
but she's the most famous kid in the
world
no totally but I feel like every year
there's like one clear person who like
probably is gonna win and more often
than not they don't
yeah but it's never been this clear
we've never had someone who is a perfect
dancer and a 10 out of 10 millions of
followers most following person hundreds
of Millions
most followed person on the platforms
yeah no and then the network darling
yeah
um so this was the first season that
Dancing with the Stars was on a streamer
and not on cable and I definitely feel
like it it affected like the It showed
the publicity of it like I feel like no
one was talking about it I agree I
recently I don't know when people were
voted off people who I follow on
Instagram or voted off that's right
Jesse James Decker
oh she was on the season she made pretty
far I think
um well Shangela made it pretty far I
think she was the first drag queen ever
on um
dancing with the star she made it to top
four so she was in the episode last
night and for their final dance her
partner came out in drag it was really
cute and funny that's so cute the top
four were Gabby from The Bachelorette
Shangela uh Wayne Brady and Charlie
demilio
yeah so Charlie
are you thinking what I'm thinking what
are you thinking what I'm thinking yes
of course we can't say it on the time
yeah it's like old school inside family
joke you guys want to care but like yeah
yeah simpatica
um I'm happy for Charles and
I just like I'm like okay I can't
believe it's actually pretty cool for
Dancing With the Stars that she was on
the show you know
so every couple of years
they actually get someone who's not like
on their way down
yeah even chandela chandela's at the top
of her game and what's so cool about
Shangela
is that if you watched her season of the
show like she got out in the beginning
and she was like
pretty unremarkable in terms of her
memory but she had like these iconic
moments that like became so much a part
of drag history that she like never even
won she never but she's like literally
one of the most famous Queens from the
show um welcome to the place like
Shangela that's like that reminds me of
like the bachelor I feel like there are
so many people like that yes we're
unremarkable on their season but are so
big in like the Canon yeah I don't mean
unremarkable because she's like fighting
and everything of the story but she got
out early and she there's a million
girls like her and we don't we don't
know her name she's on that HBO show
with Eureka and Bob the drag queen we're
here she gets like unbelievable she's on
Dancing With the Stars when I tell you
no it reminds me it reminds me of
American Idol like Jennifer Hudson not
America I know like so many people who
were on it who didn't go very far but
have these huge careers now yeah like 10
years ago made it through four or five
episodes is the biggest drag queen in
the world now like it makes no sense you
know yeah also reminds me of like
America's Next Top Model
some of the people who have come up for
the show like who became pretty loves to
re-watch America's Next Top Model you
should yeah
are you ready for our next story
if it's the next story that's brought to
you by Kitsch I would say that it is
when did Beauty get so complicated so
much about too much money not enough and
of crap that works for you well that's
why Kitsch was created to simplify
self-care and beauty products that give
you a major boost so you can go on to
your next thing kitchens offering
game-changing time-saving Beauty
Essentials for your hair Skin and Body
whatever your budget whatever your skin
type whatever your hair type kids
believes that you deserve little
indulgences at affordable prices morning
noon and night their best sellers
include satin pillowcases caps and eye
masks if you wake up with like a Rat's
Nest invest in satin pillowcases if you
uh use an eye mask satin eye masks it
will literally take your hair from like
a 10 in the morning to a four it's just
I no longer have to give myself a full
blowout every morning if I did it the
day before it's a game changer shampoo
and conditioner bars so it's bottle free
Beauty it's really smart it's great for
the planet great for your hair they have
heatless satin curling rollers that I
have but I have them because I saw them
on Tick Tock like a year ago
um great way to remove heat damage for
your hair and get really beautiful curls
without damaging your hair they have
quick dry hair towels which has become a
new favorite thing of mine because my
hair takes four days to dry it's insane
they also have the classic hair ties and
scrunchies and major shout out to their
claw Clips because I have so much my
hair I can't even fit into like I can't
go to like Amazon I can't buy just a
regular claw clip the kitchens are
really out here holding my entire hair
so kitchen is your One Stop Shop for all
your holiday gifting for your family the
besties all the resties who deserve a
little something this year right now
kids is offering discounts site-wide
anywhere from 25 all the way up to 60
off all month all the month of November
when you go to mykitch.com toast so that
discount can be up to 60 off certain
items at my kitchen which is spelled
m-y-k-i-t-s-c-h.com slash toast plus
kitchens daily flash sales they have
unbelievable deals so make sure to check
back often that's mykitch.com toast for
huge holiday discounts everything you
need for Holiday gifting or just to
treat yourself today's episode is also
sponsored by Bruce an electric
toothbrush that will change the way you
think about brushing your teeth with
powerful Sonic technology and Ultra
Gentle bristles the brush redefines what
it means to have super clean teeth it's
like that feeling when you just leave
the dentist a whole a fresh whole mouth
clean but every single day so when you
get the brush kit that includes the
electric toothbrush three extra brush
heads a magnetic charging station and a
Sleek travel case the brush is so far
fabulous because it uses
industry-leading Sonic technology to
produce 42 000 brush Strokes per minute
which is 300 times 300 brush Strokes per
minute this helps with deep cleaning and
those hard to reach places if you
haven't switched over to an electric
toothbrush yet Bruce is a great brand to
try it out with because electric
toothbrushes can be very unnecessarily
pricey and Bruce is really affordable
compared to other ones on the market
it's very beautiful comes in different
colors they have like different drops
every season
um and the charger is really like not
bulky and gross and does take up a lot
of space on your counter the battery
life also lasts four weeks so it lasts
an entire 30 days on a full charge
making it perfect for travel and keeping
your countertop charger cord free it is
Slim and Sleek easy to throw into your
purse or bag on the daily you can also
get 20 off when you pick up your brush
brush kit and the plan when you go to
brush.com toast that's 20 off when you
go to
b-r-u-u-s-h brush.com slash toast great
thank you mclared you're welcome okay
our next story more details have are
coming out about Lizzie savetsky leaving
the room outside of New York page six
has an updated story about Lizzie
savetsky's departure from The Real
Housewives of New York uh they are
recounting the story in full so I'm
going to share as well I just want to
say after we had spoken about this I
like did a little digging because I'm
like nosy and I really wanted to know
what happened and I did find out from
like a few people who like would know I
found out the exact same story so I
believe that this is true yes there's a
lot of detail too yes okay so um and the
headline is a little misleading it makes
it seem like Lizzie's out here slinging
the n-word
the headline this headline is Lizzy
sobetsky actually left rahoni after a
behind the scenes controversy when she
first left they talked about she talked
about in the statement talked about how
you know she was experienced by the way
that was a headline yesterday
um it's the headline hold on it's the
headline on the art they might have
changed it but it also might there might
be a different headline like when you on
the
home page you know how sometimes they do
that yeah but I literally
I Lizzy savesi actually left Roni after
hubby's n-word controversy yeah
that's not it anymore so page six I'm
just gonna read those things so everyone
just yeah story time
so page six reported last week and they
said Well we'd heard there was more to
the story production insiders downplayed
other drama beyond the online bullying
now it turns out that in fact things
went off the rails big time a few weeks
ago while sovetsky was filming a scene
with co-star Brynn Whitfield and got
worse from there page six is told that
Whitfield had asked Orthodox Jew
sobetsky who has a reputation as a
Matchmaker if she'd set her up with a
Jewish man but saveske said that while
she has no problem with Jews dating
Gentiles she prefers only to set up Jews
with other Jews sources said she added
that Orthodox Jews favor marriages
between Jews to preserve the ethnic
lineage we're told that she explained
that Judaism is not just a belief system
but also a people sources say that
Whitfield felt affronted and said
something to the effect that sebetsky's
terminology sounded like that was used
quote by horrific people meaning Nazis
who did Evil things to your people would
take which shocked Lizzy
and that's what we had last week yes
according to multiple insiders the
tension caused by the scene led to an
off-camera phone call between Lizzy and
Brynn during which they discussed the
power of racial slurs page six was told
that Brynn who was half black used the
n-word during the call but rather than
using the term n-word she said the word
it represents in full we're told the
whole thing she said she cut out right
right page six was told that civetsky
got the impression that Bryn planned to
tell other cast members that savetsky
had also used the n-word during the call
sources say that Lizzie's husband Dr Ira
savitsky was outraged and reported the
alleged incident to the show's producers
but page six was told that when he
recounted the call Ira also said the
actual word rather than saying the
n-word yeah uh page six heard he later
apologized but the damage was done and
they're told that's when conversations
began about the pair exiting the show
insiders were Keen to point out that
Lizzie really did also experience an
overwhelmingly overwhelming value of
anti-Semitism online and that the n-word
incident alone was not the sole reason
for her leaving the show
yeah I mean um so now everyone is being
like well she put out the statement
about anti-Semitism she was using it as
a front and like let's not go there
because honestly I'm sure she like when
she was dealing with this controversy
and then the shitstorm she probably had
in her DMS was I it certainly was a part
of it and I don't feel like we should
discount that because I feel like that's
rude yeah no and if you want to see the
anti-Semitism just go to any of like the
Bravo Instagram accounts announced that
Lizzie was going to be a cast member
when they announced that Lizzie was
leaving and just read the comments like
that we know we don't have to like be
privy to her DMS to know what she saw
um but this incident is so bizarre to me
I mean
so
first off I believe that this is what
happened because me too this level of
detail like I don't think that they they
are Conjuring it up out of nowhere like
and this
I think is something that
would happen and then get like you know
kind of blown up in the in the
production Bravo sphere and enough to
like make Lizzy either leave or be fired
right also
um this just goes to show you like it
never ends well when husbands get
involved like this like leave this to
the women because I'm sure Lizzy like
wants to kill her husband right now like
he was doing it I don't think he has any
bad intentions I don't think he
frequently uses racial slurs I don't
think that's fair assessment to make
but in this one mistake in this heated
moment because he wanted to defend his
wife and wanted to make sure a cast
member who clearly just has she clearly
just doesn't like Lizzy
um doesn't you know go around saying
really defamatory things about his wife
he slipped up and made a mistake
um
it it changed the whole game because you
can't just go around saying that even if
he meant it he was not there was no like
in malicious intent he wasn't calling
someone the slur he was repeating what
he had heard I get it yeah you still
can't say it but like it's very
different than going up to someone and
using it as a slur it's very different
um having said that I just think you
know husbands should stay out of things
because like they just don't know how
this works you know
yeah
yeah the whole I mean I think I imagine
for Lizzy like it was just like a
compounding of things and I think the
idea that one now that her husband said
this and and then she was on the call
and Bryn was gonna say that maybe that
Lizzie had said it it was like you know
between this we don't need this and we
don't need the anti-Semitism that we're
running and like we have kids and this
isn't worth it forget it
no and I'm sure she was freaking out if
she had a phone call with a girl she's
arguing with and her take away from the
phone call is that she's going to tell
people that Lizzie used the n-word like
that's such a terrible thing for people
to think about you I'm sure her and her
husband were freaking the [ __ ] out yeah
and they ran to production so that they
could get ahead of it and they'd like
help and they made it work right and it
seems like they made it worse to
themselves and then production didn't
really probably help at all
um so they either I don't know if she
was fired or if she left on her own yeah
that's still the show is turning out to
be termed like I feel like they can't
like this rhony reboot is like cursed
yeah
I don't know what will be I don't know
if any of this footage is going to be
used I feel like it's actually like a
really kind of murky area that they
probably will stay away from usually
it's like if they have footage like we
have to see it but I don't know if they
want to be Associated this is supposed
to be a show about like rich women being
rich and that's what happened without
Nazis and racial slurs that's what
happened with last Rony too where they
didn't even have a reunion because there
was allegations of racism that were
investigated and then they didn't even
do they didn't even go deal with it
again and they said you know what
goodbye to all of you we're bringing you
yeah I don't think that this is what
they want they want to be happening
again so I don't know how they'll handle
it it definitely doesn't bode well for
the new season I also have to say so
Andy has like spoken about Lizzy's
departure a couple times I saw a video
um Hollywood Life Hollywood Life he sat
down with me Julie who I love her Jewish
of red-headed Jewish Queen she asked
about the Lizzie sabetsky stuff and I
think it was before this report yeah
from page six so he was just talking
about how she left and there was
anti-Semitism and it's bad and it's sad
and it was so weird to me because he was
like yeah she experienced a lot of
anti-Semitism he was like I know I
posted something about Judaism and the
back like the comments that I got were
insane and like so horrifying and it's
just a sad state that we live in it's
like no it was it's like you
are Jewish are no no but you are Bravo
and it's like if your fans are creating
an anti-semitic environment that's just
a sad State no Andy I feel like and I
love Andy and I've had to come to this
realization like in a sad way I feel
like in terms of like Jewish leaders in
our community like Andy has been such a
letdown for me like always and forever
like I mean I think his I think his mere
presence as like a Jew who's like funny
and gay and well-loved I think it's
great and he incorporates like Mazel
like I think he's a great representative
for us but when it comes to being like
an advocate for our community I have
felt like time and time again he is
always letting me down and that
interview before we knew about the
situation it was just like Lizzie
leaving from anti-Semitism was so
disingenuous I felt like he couldn't
have [ __ ] cared less I was so let
down and that's just like the vibe I
never I know certain Jewish celebrities
like are always going to be there for
our community to like speak up and I
know Andy will never be that no and it's
like bare minimum like a tweet and it
just feels so disingenuous I don't think
he the way that I feel is like he
doesn't feel connected to the community
at all no and it's like if he were the
advocate that we need and like okay so
Lizzy came on and she's getting all this
anti-Semitism anti-zionism and he's
seeing that instead of just like being
like it's a sad State Twitter is a
cesspool like bring on some more juice
some more zionists and I know like No
And like double down not like be like oh
and so Lizzy couldn't do it because our
audience is just too anti-semitic which
is just so sad no it's so true like he's
really Time After Time like he's such a
letdown like I feel like
it's really upsetting and I feel like
people might be like and and him being a
disappointment is a separate
conversation I feel like people might be
like well maybe he knew about this
situation and just was like saying you
know um
so then he could have said like oh well
there's like other things that happen
that night I'm not even I don't want to
use this Hollywood live interview that's
I have always felt this way I've always
felt this way but I feel like if it if
maybe that's the reason why he gave
nothing in that interview he could have
been like well there was some stuff that
happened off camera as well that
um viewers might see we'll get more
context that led to Lizzie's departure
just more you know instead of being like
anti-Semitism man worse
put the letter on the show
like I find that I'm constantly like
reminding myself that Andy Cohen's
Jewish which is really never good like a
good place to be because if you if I if
I forget that means you're like never
talking about it you know we've had this
conversation before I think on the show
and like we disagree because you're like
he's not a great you know Champion for
the Jewish people but it's great that
he's like showing Jewish culture like
Mazel and a lot of the verbiage and he's
just Jewish and and that's good I I
think it's the opposite like I feel like
if you're gonna use all of our stuff as
your shtick like you better be there for
us when it matters so if you don't want
to stick up for us then like just don't
do all the rest of it no I see that too
but I still I still believe what I said
because like when you think of such a
wide reach of of Bravo and like so many
people who have like never even met a
Jew and have this like idea of what
Judaism is in their heads just to see
like this like funny successful like I
don't know I do think part of it is good
I mean I don't
like just go all in or or just be like
everyone else who's like a
a Jew and name only yeah
no it's definitely upsetting I thought
that interview was really weird really
weird yeah this is what it is you know
our anti-semitic fan base would not
accept Lizzy and therefore she left
our next story is so exciting on so many
levels that I can't begin to tell you
okay let's go Brandi will be reprising
her role as Cinderella in a new
descendants sequel yeah it just keeps
keeps getting better so Brandi who
famously played Cinderella and Roger and
Hammerstein Cinderella announced that
she's reprising her role as the iconic
character for the upcoming Disney plus
movie called the pocket watch she said
so excited to join this amazing cast and
reprise my role as Cinderella in the
Disney Descendants sequel the pocket
watch so the pocket watch is a spin-off
to The Descendants Trilogy which you
know I love so much it's snitch and I's
favorite movies and it's back in The
Descendants World in auradon and here is
the premise for all of the mamas who
have been forced to watch this movie and
found themselves really liking it the
movie follows the story the movie
musical follows the story of red who was
played by Kylie Cantrell she's the
rebellious teenage daughter of the Queen
of Hearts that's the word descendants
it's evil uh characters kids like
grown-ups their daughters their
daughters and their sons she's the
teenage daughter of the Queen of Hearts
who's played by Rita Ora and oh wow her
friend Chloe who's played by Malia Baker
and she is the naive daughter of
Cinderella and Prince Charming
Cinderella played by Brandy so it's
perfect and also in the original
descendants movies you know it was like
Dove Cameron Sophia Carson Cameron Boyce
and uh Jay I forget who the actor is um
and their parents so like Cameron's a
descendants of Maleficent who is played
by Christian Chenoweth it's pretty
star-studded Sophia Carson's the
descendant of evil queen who's played by
Kathy najimi
Kevin and Jimmy I [ __ ] love Kevin
najimi Cameron Boyce was the descendant
of Cruella I forgot who played her and
then um
Jay was the descendant of Jafar
so it's like the parents are always like
pretty big actors so it's like awesome
that it's Rita Ora and it's Brandy and
then The Descendants are like gonna be
like the new Big Disney stars the Dove
Cameron's yes very cool I love that like
we are officially like brandy is the
Cinderella of Our Generation when you
said Brandy like my mind I was Brandi
Glanville I'm like what she's placed
Cinderella that is so funny oh Jay was
played by Booboo Stewart who's also in
Twilight
oh I know who it is yeah and he like
loves Jacob and he's like keeps
following Jacob around Team Jacob yeah
yeah Seth Seth Seth Seth
um but wait what was I going to say
about this really quickly
oh just like a fun fact about Brandy
that I feel like nobody remembers it's
like her brother is Ray J I think
everyone remembers I don't think that
they do sound off in the comments do you
remember do you remember so I'll be
watching this movie I'll be forcing
counselors to hang out with me to watch
by the way I like how you were like to
all the other mamas who know about this
movie because they're forced to watch it
with their kids and had to you know
actually ended up enjoying it like
that's not you watched a movie when you
before you had kids no to right I wasn't
talking to myself I was talking to I got
so many messages messages from people
when I would like watch descendants and
post on my stories they're like oh my
God this movie's so good I watch it with
my kid and it's actually so good I
haven't seen any of them they're so good
the music is so good it's Kenny Ortega
so you know it's gonna slap quality
production and the concept is so good no
I I actually am not against seeing it
but speaking of like not me wearing a
Dutton Ranch shirt today when I've
literally never seen one minute of
Yellowstone poseair alert
no I'm such a poser wow but the member
the merch is cool remember back in the
day when like calling someone a poser
was like the meanest thing you could say
about them yeah now it's called a
bandwagon fan you know now like now that
I'm an honest adult like yeah I am a
poser you know yeah
her family that poses
her family that posted she [ __ ]
everyone in New York
her family that poses that was a really
good reference like what does that mean
that they're always taking pictures or
that I think she means like they're
they're fake
they're posers like they're always just
posing like they're never just like
being real yeah interesting her family
that poses anyways I'm so glad to share
that descendants news with you guys I
feel like we all needed to know it and
I'm happy for Brandy that she'll be
Cinderella once again she'll be
reprising this iconic role um if only
Whitney Houston was alive to to join
yeah but they should get the guy who
played Prince Charming to play Prince
Charming like I know because he never
really got anywhere after that no so he
should be available he's free
our fifth and final story
is a follow-up to something we were
talking about yesterday Kendall Jenner
and Devin Booker are no longer together
the former couple who started dating in
2020 quietly broke up last month
according to people a source said both
have incredibly busy schedules right now
with their careers and they've decided
to make that a priority
sure
so everyone is like
quaking because she was at the concert
and then Olivia and Harry broke up and
now that her and Devin have broken up
like obviously all three things are
connected but I'm kind of feeling like
now that like I'm actually feeling like
maybe they're not together because it's
like a little too obvious like what
Kendall would literally release her
breakup like two days after Harry and
Olivia no I don't think they're together
I don't think it's connected but what I
know now is Kendall is single and Harry
single so from here where do we go and
maybe she put the statement out today so
that Harry could see that she's single
because he might have just assumed she
was still dating Devin so you know girl
boss town she does like PR predictions
and whenever people break up she's
always like guessing and she actually
had a really good guess for who Harry
Styles would date who
Cami Marone
Leonardo DiCaprio's ex-boyfriend
ex-girlfriend so like they're both just
out of like really serious A-list
relationships Cami Marone is like
friendly with Haley and Kendall so she
like runs in that crew she lit she
literally looks like a girl like Harry
would love
um and what was the last thing she had
like really good reasoning for it and
like I could totally see it I don't see
it okay I don't he's gonna date someone
just like Olivia Wilde that was is very
unexpected now this Kendall being single
at the same time that Harry's single is
definitely convincing me of what you
were saying yesterday that like they
should get back together they could and
that they're meant to be I still I think
that they might like try again but I
think that it won't work out because
they're too similar
absolutely love to be wrong more than
anything I've actually thought about
um them two together because we had a
really interesting conversation
yesterday about like their personalities
and stuff
um and the more I think about it like
the more I actually think like Harry
like does not like Kendall like on a
personality level like I'm sure he likes
shares a friend but like
I I actually I don't find them to be
even remotely compatible okay
that's just what I think
I I and that might just be like my like
jealousy
um like seeping in because like I know
Harry would love my personality yeah
I wonder what he's looking for in
someone's personality I feel like he
likes a serious woman
I just wondering what he's looking for
period like is he looking to get married
not immediately but I I imagine
immediately likes being in a
relationship I'm just going based on
like what I've learned from him and
Olivia Wilde I think he likes a serious
woman I think he likes a woman with a
mind of her own and I think he likes a
little kind of like a bossy older woman
sort of thing I know but I think he
likes being I don't care Grand
statements like that because he's dated
a million girls before Olivia Wilde and
like she was so different like who like
who for a long period of time like yeah
he dated a bunch of girls and it didn't
work out after five minutes because
they're not the one no so he has like a
few like long relationships that
honestly I don't know who the girls are
because like I see them on Tick Tock and
they're always talking about like I
think one of their names is Cami or
something
um Camille Camille Camille
there's a Camille who like a lot of the
first album is about
um but it was like very low-key
relationships Olivia Wilde was Far and
Away like the most public relationship
of his but I don't know if that's
because like she was the most famous
girl he dated
um or he was the most famous yet
let me get my list out oh my god of
eligibles for him but also add them both
yes of course but there might be someone
on the list
okay also add Cami Marone to the list
well no Leo and Gigi yeah Cami Marone
and Kendall Jenner now we go to Harry
Styles wow the list is getting really
long oh I had rocks it's cupping season
I need to take off Rocky he got back to
him his wife got back together cute okay
Harry Styles and Khloe Kardashian
obsessed
I actually think though personality wise
Chloe and Harry are a better match than
Kendall and Harry I agree okay
um Lori Harvey
kind of obsessed kind of obsessed
a flow is here that damn this is a small
town Harry Styles I have it Harry Styles
and Kim
they don't really do that though like
the sisters they don't date no no no
they don't but I think Kim is a better
choice than Chloe because um just
because I think she's well you're
comparing it only to Olivia Wilde and I
don't think that's fair because I don't
know Kim is Olivia like no they're
similar girl boss Kim is his dream girl
I don't think so actually he hangs out
with Kendall to get closer to Kim and
you know what he said why don't you
break him to my concert from a physical
perspective like his type is all the
same it's like a literally model tall no
boob like tiny girls Giselle
perfect literally perfect by the way
yeah Olivia Jade I wouldn't be surprised
oh my God I'm obsessed I wouldn't be
surprised if she found herself but I
think you can get into Harry's house I
think you can take her off the list like
she is really with Jacob lordy okay he's
also on the list I don't wanna I would
take them both out you think should I
take off Aza Gonzalez and Jason Momoa
too no I haven't heard about them in a
while I feel like they could have
fizzled
no I think that's good news that we
didn't hear anything
yeah no okay
goodbye I'm happy I'm always happy when
someone comes off the list me too
because we're sending them hopefully
onto a really beautiful ship but there
are some people who I feel like are
going to be here
for a long time like who
Josh Groban
yeah um but I feel like Josh Groban
probably dates a lot but like we don't
hear about it because it's like industry
people or like nobodies I feel like you
could just go on an app as Josh G and I
think you could do I think you on The
Bachelor is Josh G
is Chris Evans dating someone to be just
report that yes ignore me
ignore me okay goodbye Chris goodbye
you need to prove yourself yeah
um you were bigger than the whole Sky I
love that song me too that's sad what
was the story we were reporting on
okay
oh you can put Devin Booker on the list
too
yeah
um I actually felt like for a while like
that was Kendall's like Dr like end I
thought that they were definitely OTP I
thought they were really similar and
they started to look alike in my brain
so when couples start to look like
that's how you know they're like soul
mates yeah they were together for a
really long time in a private and so
private and so that was like a real
relationship it was a movie that felt
like a real real movie yeah so that was
sad but um the possibilities now are
endless it's really a great time to be
young and in Hollywood it always is it
always is so true yeah so those are the
past five and you know we're two for two
this week with stunning stories let's
hope today turns out some more
sentencings some more this some more
that breakups makeups so tomorrow's
episode which is our final episode of
the week before Thanksgiving is just as
juicy as today's and yesterday's I think
it will be
so that's our show anything you want to
say to the peeps before we wrap up
got a busy day so I'll keep you abreast
on my ig me too come out make sure
you're listening to tomorrow's episode
to see how my Broadway show is Titanic
the Titanic experience can't wait for
the updates
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so at
Spotify iTunes Stitch or public radio
iheartradiocastbox all the places so
when we listen to podcasts find us the
toast and leave a five star review about
how
talented we are hope you guys have an
increase Tuesday and we'll see you
tomorrow for hump day bye